do you remember how it was to buy a
computer back in the early 2000s for the
first day or two after buying a new
computer we would spend all of our time
setting it up we would install things
like Microsoft Office Chrome Adobe Flash
drivers uTorrent and maybe a few games
we would also spend hours waiting for
all of our files to transfer from our
old hard drive to our new hard drive and
who could forget the countless restarts
that we would have to endure after each
and every install but regardless of how
exactly this setup process looked for
you one thing that we would all do to
finish the coronation of our new
computers was install antivirus
protection software we would use a
macafe CD or a Norton flash drive and
enable our oneye free trials that came
with the computer we all felt that this
was a necessary part of not only keeping
our data safe but keeping our computers
operational as fatal computer viruses
were a diamond dozen after this initial
setup was done we used usually see
McAfee or Norton every time we boot up
our computers informing us that they're
doing a malware scan to make sure that
our computers are safe and every couple
of months we would get a popup telling
us that McAfee had detected a trojan
virus and that we can eliminate this
threat with just one click as we clicked
eliminate threat on these popups for a
moment we would feel an overwhelming
sense of relief because from experience
we all knew how annoying it was to deal
with a virus and this feel would make
the $50 annual subscription more than
worth it but computers have come a long
way since then and anti software has
become a sort of relic of Computer
History to be honest I'm not complaining
because while I do have some font
memories of using Windows XP with McAfee
I always hated McAfee that crap made the
computer slow and laggy and I'm glad we
no longer have to deal with antivirus
software but how could this be with
every every passing year cyber crime is
becoming a larger and larger threat and
the tech industry is pouring
increasingly large amounts into fighting
against hackers and criminals well join
me as we take a look back at how anti
virus protection somehow lost its place
in our increasingly Tech driven
World antivirus software has clearly
been left behind by the rapidly evolving
Tech world someone else that's being
left behind is the general public whose
savings and income are getting crushed
by high inflation and this is where our
bond investing platform Silo may be able
to help with Silo you can lend money to
the largest corporations and the US
federal government and in return they'll
pay you back with historically High
interest rates of currently 4 to 7%
legendary investors like Warren Buffett
are well aware of this and that's why
they've been buying hundreds of billions
of dollars worth of bonds with Silo you
too can invest in bonds with no markups
and the Peace of Mind of $500,000 worth
of sipc insurance and a $2.5 million
worth of FDIC insurance so if you would
like to stay one step ahead of inflation
and lock in high interest rates for
yourself please consider checking out
Silo in the description below but anyway
to answer why we no longer use antivirus
software we first have to address why we
used to use antivirus software to begin
with normally with these types of things
there is no pinpoint a factor usually
it's just poor security infrastructure
across the board that has gotten better
over the years but when it comes to
computer viruses there actually is a
guilty culprit and that's none other
than Microsoft you see Windows XP was
fundamentally flawed when it came to
security you know how sometimes you go
onto a sketchy or old website and you
get this warning your connection is not
price private attackers might be trying
to steal your information well this
warning basically describes the entirety
of Windows XP internet because Microsoft
basically botched how Windows XP
communicated with the internet now I'm
no cyber security expert but from what I
gather the issue surrounding Windows XP
centers around raw sockets whenever a
file or piece of data is sent over the
internet you have two main parts one is
the actual file itself and the other is
a header that contains the metadata of
the file for example how big the file is
if raw sockets are not enabled this
metadata is automatically calculated
based on the attributes of the file
however if raw sockets are enabled like
it was with Windows XP you have the
ability to manually Define this metadata
in
99.99% of instances this doesn't matter
at all but for someone with malicious
intent this becomes free lunch for
example someone could misrepresent a 2
GB file as a 2 megabyte file if the
computer knew the true size of the file
maybe it would have stopped it due to
its abnormal size but since it doesn't
this allows random crap to be downloaded
onto your computer and that's just a
basic example essentially raw sockets
allowed hackers to misrepresent data
that was being transferred over the
internet to Windows XP computers now you
might be inclined to think that this was
just an honest oversight Microsoft just
didn't realize that people would use raw
sockets in this manner and that may have
been true maybe Microsoft didn't realize
it initially but Security Experts like
Steve Gibson were quick to point it out
even before the launch of XP but despite
these warnings Microsoft went ahead and
launched XP with raw sockets making the
Osa virus magnet the shortcomings of XP
however were only half the story as
Internet Explorer was equally as guilty
if you're familiar with web development
you you've probably heard of HTML CSS
and JavaScript these are the fundamental
pillars that make modern websites
functional HTML gives structure to the
page CSS gives design to the page and
JavaScript gives functionality to the
page but Internet Explorer could also
run another programming language Visual
Basic script or VBS at first glance this
might sound like an advantage iie
supported more languages making the
browser more versatile this is probably
what Microsoft thought as well but there
was one major problem VBS allowed IE to
do tasks outside of the browser this was
actually kind of what made VBS special
in the first place given that Windows
applications and system administration
used VBS a VBS script on iie could be
used to do General computer tasks this
is of course great when used the right
way but when used the wrong way well
this becomes really dangerous in fact
this is why it was so dangerous to open
unknown emails back back in the day
hackers would give virus files names
like hello.txt VBS or hello. dos. VBS
these seemed like harmless text files
but in reality these files had the
ability to Breck your computer and
that's exactly what happened to many
unsuspecting users and those are just
two of the biggest vulnerabilities of
early computers much of Microsoft's
early software was plagued with such
vulnerabilities leading us to the rise
of antivirus software
to be honest we can't blame Microsoft
too much back in the late 9s and early
2000s the number one priority for
Microsoft was to create stable
functional software there was simply so
much to do here that they weren't able
to give security the care that it really
needed and it wasn't until viruses
started going rampant that it really
became clear how big of a short fa this
really was fortunately though we would
see antivirus software from companies
like McAfee and Norton pick up the slack
but what exactly did such software even
do well from an overarching perspective
the functionality of antivirus software
is quite straightforward they basically
just regularly scan all of the files on
your computer identify s files and urge
you to delete them the magic of this
software was really its identification
algorithms which usually boiled down to
three main methods starting with
signature based detection this is by far
the most archaic and least effective
type of virus detection basically the
virus detection software has a repo of
known computer viruses and references to
how their code looks if the software
detects that one of your files has the
same code it'll flag it this however
only works with viruses that are already
known and added to the software's repo
so it's completely ineffective against
new viruses and old viruses whose code
have been creatively re arranged and
this brings us into the second type of
virus detection heuristic base detection
this is basically an evolved version of
signature-based detection instead of
looking for exact matches in code this
detection looks for matches in
functionality within the code this
should theoretically protect you against
viruses that use similar methods and
exploits but likely the most effective
type of virus detection is
behavior-based detection instead of
focusing on the code this type of
detection f focuses on what computer
files are actually doing is a file
randomly duplicating itself and
destroying your disk space is a file
randomly trying to access your system
files is a file randomly trying to
corrupt store data and so on and so
forth aside from these scans antivirus
software usually also comes with some
sort of firewall this might sound like
some sort of advanced security measure
but really a firewall is just a gate
between your computer and the internet
whenever you download a file either
knowingly or or unknowingly the firewall
will run these same sort of scans on the
file you want to download and block them
if necessary hearing all this you're
probably thinking that all of this
sounds a bit too simplistic is that
really all that antivirus software was
doing well it's obviously a lot easier
said than done but you're not wrong
accomplishing the same tasks as these
antivirus software is not particularly
hard especially for a software giant
like Microsoft and that's precisely why
they started addressing these issues
themselves starting from Windows 7
Microsoft would start shipping their own
firewall with Windows but the wheel jump
forward it didn't happen till Windows 8
this is quite ironic given that Windows
8 is usually viewed in a super negative
light as Microsoft's worst OS of all
time but it turns out that Windows 8
actually made huge leaps in terms of
security you see Windows 8 came
pre-installed with a tool called Windows
Defender which was basically just an
outof the-box version of Microsoft's
antivirus software Microsoft Security
Essentials this made Windows 8 the first
version of Windows to come pre-installed
with full anti virus protection software
Windows 10 and eventually 11 built upon
this with auto updates and more security
but no one really gave this a second
thought everyone was too busy talking
about the horrible Windows 8 tiles which
to be honest I don't think we that bad
in the first place but over time people
did slowly notice Le us to the death of
antivirus
protection there was never really a
pivotal turning point when people just
suddenly ditched antivirus software
rather it was much more of a gradual
decline you might forget to renew your
McAfee subscription one year and
suddenly it's been 6 months since you
forgot to renew you realize that you
didn't have any issues over the past 6
months and decide to to just not Renew
at all General perception also plays a
big role in this one of the main reasons
that people were so intent on buying
antivirus protection was because they
were constantly hearing horror stories
from their friends and family and the
News Uncle Joe just happened to open an
unsuspecting email from what seemed like
his son and boom his computer got fried
these are the types of stories that
drove people to buy antivirus protection
back in the day but we rarely hear about
such stories nowadays and one of the
main reasons for this is that all of us
have become way more techsavvy we know
when a download is sketchy we know not
to open emails about Amazon refunds and
we know when a website is fake also even
if we somehow do get a computer buus we
all know how to restore our computers
and get all of our data back from the
cloud nowadays this is really just an
inconvenience and a hassle not a game
changer like it used to be moreover our
internet usage nowadays is far more
curated virtually all of our internet
traffic goes through Google Facebook
Amazon apple and other reputable big
tech companies this isn't to say that
there's no more fears regarding cyber
security because there absolutely is
however the fears have morphed nowadays
the concerns are about keeping your data
private using vpns keeping your identity
safe and so on as such the goal of
hackers has also morphed hackers are no
longer trying to Breck your computer
with a trojan virus in fact that would
be counterproductive as hackers want you
to use your computers for as long as
possible with no issues so that they can
steal as much data as possible so
unfortunately keeping safe online is
still very much a concern but
traditional antivirus software simply no
longer plays a big role in this and
that's what happened to antivirus
software if you don't want to be left
behind like antivirus software please
consider checking out Silo in the
description below but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
[Music]
one